I'm buying Ryan I'm from clover South
Carolina and I'm the world's most unique
Bayern Munich fan see for yourself
[Music]
the reason have the only Bayern Munich
prosthetic guy in the world is because
in 2016 I was diagnosed with ocular
melanoma which is an ultra rare eye
cancer the doctors kind of agreed that
you have one choice so I went with lose
two I not lose my life I lost my out of
cancer so instead of getting that
regular op right we don't get recognized
the reason I got the Bayern münich ah
it's just that instant question of dude
what happened to your eye and that leads
you into awareness for ocular melanoma
it starts the conversation through all
this Bayern Munich's been amazing they
helped with the cost of the surgery
because I don't have insurance so
everything's coming out of pocket I mean
to me they're the only club in the world
no matter we lose no matter the wind we
stick together of course it was in our
interest to help the guy who is soul
into by meaningful as it's clear that do
whatever we came in terms of supporting
a guy like you the Bavarian runs deep in
me my grandfather served in Germany my
father was born in Germany this is a
team that I grew up with there in the
last 14 months lives gotten tremendously
harder that spot behind me I'm always
hit by a driver that was distracted
that's it that's life-changing I
shouldn't have made it I really
shouldn't have you look at the car I
mean it was crushed it's been he'll
still is but the thing that's kept me
going through all of this it's that
Bayern saying me Asami we are who we are
as a Bayern fan we never give up one of
the the big factors in all of this is
Franck Ribery this whole thing with the
scar from when he was a kid and in the
car wreck that he was in he's got his
big scar and he said every time he looks
at it it's it's what made him the man
that he is today
Josh Kennedy
iron and upon socialism a star moves
insta gamma in globish Gaussian aspect
of my service Amato le Bojana on
decision we're in Charlotte North
Carolina
we're here at hooligans my second home
today Bayern plays Schalke how many
Premier League you got Cam Newton no
fire band will wear that these are the
guys that ground me they'll make fun of
my eyes but I know it's coming from the
heart it's it's a place where we're a
football family this is who I am
accept it or you don't when I look in
the mirror and I see this eye that scar
made me the man that I am today no
matter what's stacked up against me
I'm gonna get through it with my legs
not working and without what I bought
I'm gonna do just like my Munich goes
I'm gonna win this in the end
[Applause]